don't do that to each other are you guys
okay what on Earth
last night's episode of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians was freaking stacked
with tears f-bombs you shut the [ __ ] up
and blood literally bleeding no it's
crazy yeah you heard me blood crazy
here's what went down the episode kicks
off showing fans the immediate aftermath
of that now Infamous blowout between Kim
and Courtney do it already
and turns out the hits kept coming
literally okay separate no no no
you don't stop never
hey take your nails in me guys stop oh
Courtney Courtney you guys stop it don't
do that to each other are you guys okay
what on Earth the most iconic part of
this whole fight is Kim leaving her mark
on the wall yeah that's her makeup all
over Chloe's pristine White Walls and
Chloe being a whole damn mood wiping it
off
core drops a ton of f-bombs
your reactions why were you about to hit
me are you crazy I'm not gonna hit you
don't take someone else's side I do
that's my issue with you pointing your
finger like this point my finger you
shut the [ __ ] up Courtney if I hit you
you would be knocked out good [ __ ] do
it I don't resort to violence you're
crazy
with me for too long I'm not gonna hear
it anymore yeah like a ton oh and she
cries
and she throws some major shade towards
Kim I don't want to be here okay but
guys if you thought that was Savage get
this court scratched Kim so hard she
actually made her bleed but she should
leave she's literally bleeding anyway
Court makes it pretty damn clear she's
really over being on the show I just
feel like every day it's like they just
like pick on me and I just can't
I just can't do it anymore I was anxious
about filming this season it doesn't
make me happy like I don't want to miss
out on like time with my kids and like
it's not worth it but she also admits
that she regrets getting violent with
her sister and in a strange turn of
events she says she's actually more mad
at Chloe than she is at Kim
weird right
Kim and Courtney actually put their
differences aside for a hot sec to make
good on a trip they had planned to
Armenia but court totally wasn't feeling
all the paparazzi and she says she's
like so over fame
I just I'm like
I don't like
being
a celebrity when the girls returned to
La the drama is back on but this time
it's court and Chloe going at it that's
just such a [ __ ] though like the way
that you talk you don't think you're a
[ __ ] by shutting down the whole time
just because you cry
just because you can sit here and cry
doesn't mean I'm not hurting too just
because I'm not a crier they make peace
sort of
and Court finally gets what she's been
wanting a break from filming the show
I've decided to take a big step back
from filming and really just pick and
choose what I
will allow cameras to follow now when I
have something that I find is
interesting to film or that I would feel
excited to film that I do that
when E.T caught up with the three
sisters back in October Court hinted
that this was coming you mentioned that
you might be ready to say goodbye to
Keeping Up with the Kardashians where
are you at on that
um I'm just decided to
spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there and still
but I'm not saying goodbye do you think
the show can continue going if you lose
a sister we definitely love Courtney and
we will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but
they all come back